elmo's y podemos usar todo lo que hemos
aprendido acerca de diferenciación con
creatividad los puntos mínimos y máximos
y los puntos de infracción para poder
graficar una función sin tener que usar
una calculadora gráfica digamos que
nuestra función
f x es igual a 3x a la cuarta potencia
menos 4 por x al cubo más 2 y por
supuesto ustedes siempre pueden graficar
una función enfocándose en los puntos
que no son de interés para poder tener
una forma general de la función sobre
todo si nos enfocamos en las partes que
podemos inferir de esta función usando
nuestra caja de herramientas de
derivadas lo primero que queremos hacer
es encontrar los puntos críticos aquí le
escribiré nuestros puntos críticos y
para que recordemos a qué se refiere
esto de puntos críticos se refiere a
aquellos puntos en los que la derivada
de fx
0 efe prima de x igual a 0 o no está
definida o esté indefinida esta función
luce bastante diferenciable en todos sus
términos así que los puntos críticos que
nos interesan bueno les puedo decir que
definitivamente serán aquellos puntos en
los que esta f prima de x sea 0 este
derivada f prima de x estará definida
durante todo el dominio así que vamos a
comenzar a escribir la derivada de esta
función la derivada de esto efe prima
x
es algo bastante directo la derivada de
3 por equis a la cuarta va a ser 3 por 4
12 por x al cubo recordamos que
decrementar nos la potencia en 1
multiplicamos la constante por el
exponente y elevamos la variable al
exponente menos una unidad menos
3 x 4 vuelve a ser 12 por equis pero
ahora es 3 menos 12 y la derivada de una
constante es ser recordemos que aquí no
hay ningún cambio es una constante
entonces por eso su derivada o su
pendiente va a ser cero y ahora vamos a
concentrarnos en los puntos críticos
recordemos que los puntos críticos es
cuando todo esto es igual a cero o está
indefinido ahora puedo ver el dominio
completo de los números enteros y me doy
cuenta de que esto está definido en
todas partes podemos poner cualquier
número y nunca nos va a dar una
indefinición siempre me va a dar un
resultado por lo que vamos a tener que
encontrar en qué puntos esto es igual a
cero así pues tenemos que encontrar para
cuáles valores de x está f prima de x va
a ser igual a 0 ok bueno esto lo
escribiré extra no es necesario que se
escriba esto lo voy a escribir en
diferente color 12 x al cubo menos 12 x
x al cuadrado es igual
a 0
qué valores de x me dan esta igualdad
bueno qué podemos hacer para resolver
esto pues podemos factorizar el 12 x
factor' izamos 12 x esto lo sacamos este
término se vuelve x perdón tendríamos
que quitar el 12 x cuadrada de factor
izamos 12 x cuadrada y este término se
convierte en x y éste es menos 1
y todo esto es igual hacer simplemente
lo que hicimos fue factorizar sacar este
término y si ustedes hacen la operación
de multiplicar 12 x cuadrada por x menos
uno les va a dar esta función y esto lo
hice para facilitar poder encontrar el
punto o el valor o valores de x para los
cuales todo esto es igual a cero pues
así encontramos todas las x que pueden
hacer que este valor de toda esta
ecuación sea igual a cero y para esto
uno o ambos de estos términos tienen que
ser igual a cero así que tenemos 12 x
cuadrada igual a 0 por lo que la x por
fuerza tendría que ser igual a 0 lo que
haría que todo este término fuera igual
a 0 y el otro valor que puede darnos
esta ecuación igual a 0 es con x menos 1
igual a cero cuando x es igual a 1
y estos son nuestros dos puntos críticos
cuando x es igual a 0 y cuando x es
igual a 1
y recuerden que esos son los puntos en
donde nuestra primera derivada es igual
a 0 donde la pendiente es 0 podrían ser
puntos máximos o puntos mínimos podrían
ser puntos de inflexión podrían ser
cualquier cosa
no podemos saber mucho de ellos en este
momento pero sí sabemos que son puntos
de interés eso es lo único que podemos
decir con certeza de esto es que son
puntos de interés pero vamos a continuar
para tratar de comprender la
competividad y así poder tener un
sentido de esta gráfica así que vamos a
calcular la segunda derivada la segunda
derivada la voy a hacer en otro
colorcito la segunda derivada de fx
bueno es 12 por 3 36 por x al cuadrado
- 12 por 2 24 por equis ahora aquí hay
un par de cosas que podemos hacer ya que
tenemos esta segunda derivada podemos
responder la pregunta de si mi gráfica
es cóncava hacia arriba o hacia abajo en
cualquiera de esos puntos críticos
recuerden que si es cóncava hacia arriba
o sea tendrá una forma de un si es
cóncava hacia abajo tendrá forma de una
invertida bueno ahora vamos a evaluar
estos puntos críticos en la función de
nuestra segunda derivada así que la
segunda derivada de f en cero va a ser
igual a qué bueno 36 x 0 al cuadrado va
a ser cero menos 24 por 0 también va a
ser cero así que esto va a ser cero así
que no es ningún cabo hacia arriba ni
hacia abajo la función en este punto
podría ser un punto de transición igual
podría no serlo pero bueno no estamos
seguros todavía de qué se trata
ahora vamos a evaluar la segunda
derivada de f cuando x es igual a 1
estos 36 por 1 al cuadrado 36 por 1
queda como 36 menos 24 por 1 que de 24
36 - 24 así que 36 menos 24 va a ser
igual a 12 y este es un valor positivo
nuestra segunda derivada evaluada en 1
es positiva por lo que significa que
nuestra primera derivada la pendiente se
incrementa el cambio es positivo así que
en este punto tenemos una pendiente
cóncava hacia arriba lo que me dice que
esto probablemente sea un punto mínimo
si la pendiente que es 0 y tenemos algo
cóncavo en ese punto lo que es bastante
interesante y ahora vamos a buscar si
tenemos algún otro punto potencial de
inflexión ya sabemos que esto es un
punto potencial de inflexión vamos a
resaltarlo en rojo este es un punto
potencial pero no sabemos si realmente
hay una transición en la función en ese
punto tendremos que experimentar un
poquito más pero veamos si hay algún
otro punto de inflexión y para esto
vamos a ver si esta segunda derivada se
vuelve cero en algún otro punto 36 x
cuadrada
menos 24 igual a 0 ahora vamos a
factorizar el 12 x
12 x x
3 x 3 x 12 es 36 y x x x x cuadrado
menos 2 y todo eso es igual a 0 y vemos
que estas dos expresiones son
equivalentes y hacemos las
multiplicaciones aquí en la segunda
expresión veremos que es igual a la de
arriba y para que esta expresión se
cumpla esta parte de 12 x tiene que ser
igual a 0 en el punto en el que
obviamente x tiene que ser igual a 0 o
sea en este punto cuando x es igual a 0
todo esto vale 0 y bueno eso ya lo
sabíamos desde antes y esa otra parte
también si esto es igual a 0 se
cumpliría esta expresión
vamos a resolver la 3x
- 2 igual a cero
3x es igual a 2 y x es igual a dos
tercios este es otro punto de interés
uno que no habíamos encontrado antes y
este podría ser un punto de inflexión y
digo que podría hacerlo porque en la
segunda derivada es definitivamente cero
en este punto y ahora lo que tengamos
que hacer es ver si esta segunda
derivada es positiva o negativa en ambos
lados de este punto y ya tenemos más o
menos una idea de esto podemos hacer
pruebas con un par de números ya sabemos
que si tomamos un valor de x que es más
grande que dos tercios vamos a hacer un
poquito de espacio aquí vamos a ver qué
pasa cuando x es mayor que dos tercios
mayor que dos tercios cuál va a ser el
valor de f prima de x perdón la segunda
derivada de fx vamos a elegir un valor
que esté bastante cercano pues para
darnos una idea así que permítanme
reescribir la segunda derivada de fx
igual y permíteme escribirla de esta
otra manera quizás un poquito más fácil
de trabajar con ella que es igual a 12 x
x 3x menos dos cuando x es mayor que dos
tercios
este término de aquí va a ser positivo
eso es algo definitivo cualquier número
positivo multiplicado por 12 va a dar
otro número positivo pero qué pasa con
este otro término de aquí tres por dos
tercios menos dos va a ser exactamente
ser pero cualquier cosa ligeramente
mayor que esa si yo tuviera 2.1 entre 3
esto va a ser una cantidad positiva
cualquier valor de x mayor a dos tercios
aquí me va a dar otro número positivo y
esto significa que cuando x es mayor que
dos tercios la segunda derivada en ese
valor va a ser positiva la segunda
derivada de x es mayor que 0 y en
nuestro dominio siempre y cuando x sea
mayor que dos tercios va a ser cóncavo
hacia arriba y aquí lo vemos que cuando
x es igual a 1
con calidad va a ser hacia arriba pero
qué pasa cuando x es menor a dos tercios
bueno ahora cuando x es menor vamos a
escribirlo más abajo cuando x es menor
que dos tercios vamos a reescribir la
expresión la segunda derivada de fx que
es igual a 12 x x 3x menos 2
bueno vemos que si tomamos un valor muy
lejano esto vamos a tener un número
negativo así que vamos a elegir un valor
que esté muy pero muy cerca de este 2
entre 3 que sea menor pero que aún
estemos en el dominio positivo si esto
fuera por ejemplo no se 1.9 entre 3 esto
de aquí va a ser positivo justo por
debajo de los dos tercios esta parte de
aquí va a ser positiva pero qué pasa en
esta otra parte en esta parte de acá
bueno si esto es igual a dos tercios va
a ser esta parte exactamente igual a
cero pero cualquier cosa que sea menor a
dos tercios por ejemplo tres por un
tercio va a ser igual a uno uno menos
dos va a ser igual a menos uno se van a
tener números
por lo que la segunda derivada cuando x
es menor a dos tercios justo digamos que
a la izquierda de estos dos tercios esto
va a ser menor que cero ahora el hecho
de que tengamos esa transición de algo
menor a dos tercios que tiene una
segunda derivada negativa y que cuando
tenemos algo mayor a dos tercios tenemos
una segunda derivada positiva esto nos
dice que justamente aquí tenemos un
punto de inflexión punto de inflexión
cuando x es igual a dos tercios para
nuestra función original esta de aquí
arriba y ahora tenemos otro punto
candidato a punto de inflexión y después
ya estaremos listos para graficar quiero
tener todos los puntos de infección el
máximo y el mínimo y ya tendremos todos
los elementos para graficar así que
ahora vamos a ver si x igual a 0 es un
punto de inflexión sabemos que la
segunda derivada valorada en 0 va a ser
igual a 0 pero qué pasa antes y después
de ese 0 y para que no haya confusiones
vamos a
dibujar una línea separando estas
ecuaciones cuando x
es mayor que 0
que le va a pasar a la segunda derivada
recordamos que esta segunda derivada es
igual a 12 por x por 3x menos 2 me gusta
escribirlo de esta manera porque podemos
descomponerlo en dos expresiones
lineales las cuales podemos ver de
manera independiente si son positivas o
negativas cuando x es mayor que 0 esto
de aquí va a ser algo positivo
definitivamente y esto de aquí justo
cuando estamos por encima del x mayor a
0 tenemos que asegurarnos de estar
bastante cerca de este valor digamos que
este valor va a ser en punto 1
que estamos muy muy cerca de cero
así que si esto es punto 1 al
multiplicarlo vamos a tener punto 3 - 2
este va a ser un valor negativo así que
cuando x es está un poquito por encima
de 0 la segunda derivada va a ser
negativa lo escribimos por acá la
segunda derivada de x va a ser menor que
cero la concavidad va a ir hacia abajo
lo que tiene sentido porque en un punto
vamos a llegar a una transición así que
esto es consistente desde cero hasta los
dos tercios vamos a tener una concavidad
hacia abajo y en dos tercios
comenzaremos a tener una concavidad
positiva y ahora vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando x está justo por debajo de cero
cuando x está apenas apenas por debajo
de cero escribimos nuevamente nuestra
segunda derivada de fx que es igual a 12
x x 3 x menos dos si x fuera igual a
menos punto 0 1 o menos punto 0 0 1 todo
esto va a ser negativo
esta parte de aquí va a ser negativa ya
que es un valor negativo por pequeño que
sea que se multiplica por un 12 va a dar
un valor negativo y esta otra parte que
va a ser bueno 3 por menos punto cero
uno va a ser menos punto cero 3 - 2 - 2
puntos 0 3
definitivamente vamos a tener un número
negativo acá y si se resta de otro
número se va a tener un número negativo
pero qué pasa si multiplico negativo con
negativo pues va a dar un número
positivo por lo tanto cuando x es
ligeramente menor que 0 la segunda
derivada va a ser positiva quizás esto
pueda ser un poco confuso pero ahora ya
tenemos todo lo necesario para hacer
nuestra gráfica hacemos más espacio aquí
abajo y sabemos que cuando x es igual a
1 cuando x es igual a 1 vamos a
escribirlo aquí arriba
nosotros encontramos
que cuando x es igual a 1 la pendiente
es 0 segunda derivada de f en 0 es igual
a 0
y una disculpa debí haber escrito esto
como la pendiente es igual a 0 y
encontramos esto porque nuestra primera
derivada era 0 ahí encontramos nuestro
punto crítico y sabemos que estamos
trabajando con una función cóncava hacia
arriba en este punto cóncava hacia
arriba y esto nos dice que es un punto
mínimo cóncavo hacia arriba y de hecho
podemos tener las coordenadas y hacer la
gráfica real que es el punto de este
vídeo efe de 1 a que es igual bueno
vamos a ver nuestra función original
tres por uno menos cuatro más dos tres
por uno a la cuarta menos cuatro por uno
al cubo más 23 menos cuatro más dos que
es un número positivo nos queda un 1 si
ustedes hacen la operación verán que el
resultado es 1 así que f 1 es igual a 1
ahora también sabemos que cuando x es
igual a cero encontramos que la
pendiente va a ser igual a cero pero
también encontramos que este es un punto
de inflexión la competividad cambia
antes y después de este punto así que
este es un punto de inflexión
punto de inflexión donde es cóncavo
abajo de cero cuando x es menor que cero
tenemos la concavidad hacia arriba
nuestra segunda derivada es positiva y
cuando x es mayor que 0 nuestra
concavidad va hacia abajo y no en toda
la extensión de x mayor a 0 apenas
arriba de 0 para seguir encontrando las
coordenadas tenemos que encontrar cuál
es el valor de f en 0
efe en 0 es igual vemos nuestra ecuación
tres por cero menos 40 más 2
entonces nuestra efe de cero va a ser
igual a 2 y finalmente tenemos el valor
cuando x es igual a dos tercios x es
igual a dos tercios vamos a poner el
otro color el punto cuando x es igual a
dos tercios y encontramos que este es un
punto de inflexión este fue un punto de
inflexión la pendiente definitivamente
no es cero acá porque es un punto de
inflexión y es uno de los puntos
críticos y sabemos que vamos hacia abajo
cuando x es menor a dos tercios nuestra
concavidad va hacia abajo
más menor que dos tercios y cuando x es
apenas mayor que dos tercios nuestra
concavidad vivimos aquí arriba cuando es
un poquito mayor que dos tercios
encontramos que la segunda derivada es
positiva así que va hacia arriba y una
vez más vamos a encontrar cuál es el
valor de f cuando x es igual a dos
tercios y de hecho ni siquiera tenemos
que hacer un cálculo complicado podemos
hacer una gráfica muy buena con los
puntos que ya tenemos ahora vamos a
hacer una gráfica en general
tenemos que dibujar nuestros ejes
aquí voy a dibujar
mi punto cero
12.02
vamos a hacerlo en este color
hacer un color diferente un azul ahora
voy a graficar
mi punto 1 1
este punto de aquí va a ser 1,1
ahí está la coordenada 11
y esta es la coordenada 0.2 y ahora
tenemos cuando x es igual a dos tercios
nuestro punto de inflexión que va más o
menos por acá
dos tercios aunque no sabemos
exactamente
cuál es el valor de f de dos tercios en
este punto verde coordenada dos tercios
coma efe de dos tercios
efe de dos tercios y ya que tenemos
estos puntos especificados podemos
proceder a hacer la gráfica sabemos que
cuando x es igual a 1 la pendiente es
cero así que está plano aquí y después
se viene una parte cóncava hacia abajo
que luce más o menos así en ese
intervalo donde se va elevando y sabemos
que esto se eleva a partir de que x es
mayor a dos tercios vamos a ponerlo en
otro color y sabemos que en el punto
cuando x es igual a dos tercios tenemos
una concavidad hacia arriba por eso
dibuje esta forma de 1 cuando x es menor
a 2 tercios pero mayor a 0 la concavidad
va hacia abajo déjenme dibujarlo mejor
en este intervalo la pendiente va
decrementar como pueden ver aquí vamos
comenzando con un punto de pendiente
plana y va bajando va bajando bajando
hasta que llegue al punto de inflexión
donde va cambiando la pendiente y
comienza a incrementarse de nuevo hasta
que al punto en el que se hace la
concavidad hacia arriba y cuando x es
menor que cero la concavidad va hacia
arriba así que la gráfica luce más o
menos así y también encontramos que
cuando x es igual a cero tenemos un
punto crítico aquí la gráfica la
pendiente es plana ese es un punto de
inflexión cuya pendiente también es ser
y esta industria gráfica final después
de todo ese trabajo pudimos usar
nuestras habilidades en cálculo para
encontrar todos estos puntos críticos
estos puntos de interés puntos de
inflexión para finalmente poder graficar
esta función que pues está bastante
densa y más o menos se vas a ver así si
usted es la gráfica en con su
calculadora